I built my name is Thomas and I'm from
Los Angeles I would really like to hear
your opinion on whether or not we have
free will in the conventional meaning is
there really an independent ego right
here that is in control of my every
thought in action
I think Einstein is a determinist and so
he does not believe in free will but
then there's the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle although to my understanding
the uncertainty is in our scientific
instruments and the inaccuracies of the
measurements thank you you covered a lot
of ground there uh but nobody knows
about the nature of consciousness I
think we have free will up to a point
but we are driven by deep deep things
like wanting to get food making more
people that is to say
mating and then I cannot help but notice
how much people from the same family
tend to do the same things same families
tend to do the same things just
anecdotally but clearly I know I have
made decisions based on things that
happened around me that I wouldn't have
made without being informed by history
or what I noticed I know I have now if
that turns out not to be true I'd be
very surprised now as far as the
uncertainty principle goes uncertainty
principle is roughly there's a quantum
there's a amount of energy below which
you can't measure so if you have as the
old saying is you can know where the
electron is or you can know how fast
it's going but you can't know both not
exactly because anything you would use
to measure it would inherently move the
electron or change its speed all right
that's that's the classic uncertainty
principle at work with that said I am
satisfied now as an engineer and
scientist that our brains are chemical
reactions and chemical reactions at some
level depend on quantum mechanics on the
the interaction of subatomic particles
based on this extraordinary thing called
quantum electrodynamics you alluded to
it
and so at some level there's randomness
in what we think because we're made of
chemicals that have randomness but
largely human behavior is generally
predictable there's whole schools full
of psychologists and psychiatrists who
study humans and they they come across
patterns and those patterns have got to
be part of our brains and our free wills
got to be part of that I mean I don't
mean to skirt your question but the
nature of consciousness you are living
at a time when the nature of
consciousness is not understood but it
may be very soon because we will build
computer models or computers that are as
sophisticated or as complicated or as as
messed up as human brains and they will
behave the same way as human brains as
long as they're plugged in the computers
carry on